here's here's another part of an
argument perhaps and this this is
moral perhaps legal argument that
this wasn't the case back in 2001 but it
is now
wikipedia has a reputation it's a very
important reputation because if
something appears on wikipedia a lot of
people just
assume that it's factual right um
and well what are people supposed to do
when uh lies really damaging lies
occur in that sort of situation
well they could try suing
the wikimedia foundation but
the wikimedia foundation is going to
cite section 230
they can try to sue the uh
the user but how are they going to find
out who the user is if the user is
anonymous
so they could sue there could be a class
action lawsuit against the wikimedia
foundation to the following um
by all these people who are harmed by
the wiki
wikipedia system which
basically allows all of these anonymous
people
to um to say damaging things
that have no recourse that's
itself a damaging situation for
all of those people it's a it's a
perfect class action lawsuit because
it's a whole class
that is affected by the um
by the situation do you think it would
force wikipedia wikimedia to shut down
if they were sued like that probably not
i mean
something had happened i hope i know
they ask for donations every year that
they it seems like they're bootstrapped
i don't know if they're actually getting
funded by google
they probably got enough money but you
still gotta [ __ ] they've got a lot of
money and they've got a huge endowment
and they're not
hurting for money in any way shape or
form i
had uh some smear pieces written about
me i mean it happens periodically but i
don't get it nearly as much as some
other people which is really
fascinating to me so i you know i pulled
up andy knows
wikipedia and boy is it in depth like
these people write about everything the
guy does
my wikipedia is like kind of barren and
they're like why won't anybody write
about this guy i guess no one really
cares
but when i when i had articles written
about me that smeared me i remember i
called
a lawyer i called some friends some
people with legal experience
and i was told this news article
first if an academic writes an opinion
piece
and then a news outlet says a new study
says tim poole does
x you can't sue the news outlet they're
referencing a study
now the study will claim that they just
analyzed information and are giving an
expert opinion you can't sue them either
so okay so what do you do when an
academic who's an ideologue for the
for what are they called the humanities
asserts something to be a scientific
fact when it's just their
absurd opinion nothing well when the
when a news outlet actually smeared me
definitively as the writer i talked with
a lawyer
and they said you can't sue and i said
why and they were like the things
they're saying about you are opinions
and i was like but this is a news
article they're saying tim poole did
this
and they're like yeah but that's an
opinion and i was like
i don't i i'm i'm i'm i'm flabbergasted
by this
new lawyer no no i've talked to many
lawyers and they are correct so
i i talked to lawyers for 10 years about
copyright infringement manipulation lies
and smears
and i i i'm not going to pretend to be
as as well versed as a lawyer
but i've been through this many times
the problem was when
so if they if they read an article that
says ian crossland is a white
supremacist
neo-nazi who associates with neo-nazis
those are all opinions you can't sue
them
well james o'keefe sued because the new
york times said
they were deceptively editing or
something to that effect
and this is when we got new new
precedent or at least
something you could you could reference
so far when the judge said
if you are writing a fact-based news
article or an article that's purporting
to be fact
stands to reason if you have if your
employees are injecting
or interjecting their opinions you must
inform your readers of that
this is what brings me to the argument
i'm making about wikipedia
same exact argument made by that judge
if wikipedia
is asserting two things that their
articles are
cited with reliable sources and the
articles are not opinion pieces
this is an encyclopedia right it's like
encyclopedia means fact
it's the facts about the issue but
they're not showing the user posts nor
are they putting this article was
authored by
and a list of every single person who
wrote it then wikipedia
itself is making this statement so it's
a very similar argument i'm looking at
this is what's changing the game and
it's only possible because project
veritas decided to sue
even though many lawyers probably said
you can't win
they said we're going to sue anyway i've
talked to way too many lawyers
i've talked to james about this on the
show we've talked about this and it's
very difficult
james o'keefe up on his website take
this out over at projectveritas.com
they have a donation page donate to
support our lawsuit against the new york
times they're trying to raise one
million dollars and you know what
i'm willing to bet it's gonna cost them
more than a million dollars to sue the
new york times
so when you're a small youtuber
or twitter personality or maybe you got
a hundred thousand followers
and then a news outlet that has a 24
year old
far left extremist who writes articles
for them writes
mangled garbage saying ian crossland is
a white supremacist
how are you supposed to have a million
dollars to sue a major news
organization that 20 22 to 24 year old
psychopath
has the powerful institution at their
back and they can say whatever they want
you can't so this is why we talked about
this with james of the people's
defamation defense fund we're entering a
terror we're entering territory where
everyone is a public figure a kid
standing on the stairs lincoln memorial
was what they tried arguing was an
involuntary public figure you got a
twitter account they'll argue he's a
public figure she's a public figure
therefore the actual malice standard
applies
how is somebody who is just like a
social medias are supposed to compete
with the new york times
it's a scary thing project veritas
got past a motion to dismiss and they're
they're well funded
you know i think they're a multi-million
dollar operation you can look at their
their 990s their their their tax forms
because they're a 501c3
and they have good money but they don't
they don't make nearly as much as the
new york times does the new york times
is bringing in what like 50 million a
month or some ridiculous number from
subscriptions
the new york times can just say okay
everybody halt this month we're gonna
dump 50 million to nuke james o'keefe
and what do you do it's called law fair
so james has gotten pretty far
and it's it's amazing this guy you know
the right conservatives moderates the
anti-anti-establishment we're going to
call this faction
has very few active personalities has
very few individuals willing to go
to war the left every single
person on the left for the most part is
willing to go
nuts they even throw bricks through
windows and risk jail time
but people on the right don't do that it
makes me think of david and goliath this
whole
this whole story that goliath is the
large unstoppable
warrior guy and david's this little guy
that has no chance in the eyes of the
masses of winning but
because he he actually has a chance he
knows he has a chance
and he has precision strike he's able to
throw a rock into the eye
of goliath and then blind him and then
take him down
but he really had the ability to do it
if you have no ability
don't try you're going to get killed but
james has
has righteousness on his side i believe
these people are doing the wrong thing
new york times
well it seems like they are defaming but
but twitter seems like they are
right right you you are correct but you
have to recognize david still needed the
rock and the sling
yes so there's a lot of people with
righteousness on their side or a better
word a better way to phrase it is
the truth on their side but do they have
the sling and the rock which is the
money to fundraising exactly to be able
to
pay the lawyers and if you're a random
beggar on the street
seeking to defeat goliath and people
like i don't know you and you're walking
around begging
you're not going to get the resources
you need well i like this people's
defamation
pdf pdf what p d d f
yes like basically uh an open community
fund that will help people sue for
defamation against these larger
i think wikipedia needs to be sued uh uh
you know i'll
let me tell you something i remember
when um cassandra fairbanks
sued over being defamed because someone
claimed that she flashed a white power
hand gesture
when she was just making the okay sign
it's it's not but sure whatever the
media just kept saying it was because
4chan said it wasn't congratulations now
it is
i i wonder when i see a lot of these
lawsuits i'm very curious like why the
arguments tend to be so
weak and you know typically i just
assume
i must not know enough about the law you
know to frame a popul
a proper legal argument but then
invariably these lawsuits fail
and i'm like these judges are people
they're not
morons have you tried explaining to them
in basic terms instead of just making
these ridiculous arguments
why not just say like take a look at
your honor what do you think and then
you might lose i guess there's probably
there's good lawyers and there's bad
lawyers i suppose one way to put it but
i'm wondering
why is it that i'm sitting here and i
can see what wikipedia is doing
and i can i i can i can break down for
you exactly what i see
is wrong with this and it's what i said
when you go to twitter
and you lay retweet something we know it
came from you
but wikipedia is an encyclopedia and it
doesn't list its users
in the article even if you go to the new
york times the new york times puts a
byline
so you know who wrote it am i i'll be
honest
i can't tell you who wrote anything on
my wikipedia page you know why
i'd have to go through three or four
hundred pages to look at every single
individual
to figure out what user this actually
came from even then you're only getting
ip addresses
some of them yes so it's not even an
issue of coming from users
it's just random garbage splashed into a
background that wikipedia then publishes
it under its own name
nowhere on wikipedia does it say this is
user genera does it does it say in the
article
this article is written by an amalgam of
users here are the users here's how many
there are
they're going to need to buy
wikipinion.com it is wick opinion
it basically is that's all it is it's
wic opinion i'm sure they
own that but um you know so to summarize
your point in the point that i was
making then um
wikipedia has this this
um total
how do you you put it um it
has its reputation it's asserting
putting its reputation behind the claims
the factual claims that are in the
articles
that's on the one hand now on the other
hand they
are not taking responsibility
for the anonymous contributions and yet
it is precisely
the system of anonymous contributions
that um that they're putting their
reputation behind so their
responsibility they're responsible for
the anonymity
that they they're they're uh on
principle
they're they're responsible for the
anonymity and therefore
insofar as that is the cause
of the the problem they
bear the uh the burden i wonder i wonder
i wonder i wonder
my page on wikipedia is locked right now
meaning users
can't edit it without special
permissions i mean that sounds like you
have to
you have to have a certain number of
edits i believe that sounds like
a job criteria what's the difference
between the new york times saying you
have to have approval from the editor or
wikipedia saying you have to have
approval from our editors
yeah well i mean they've got they've got
standards but the standards are supposed
to be
enforced only by the
volunteers so it's a volunteer community
that's what they're going to say
if jane doe writes an article for the
new york times
saying ian crossland punched a dog
oh gee i'm coming and it's a false
statement to
you could sue the crazy thing is even in
that case there's still actual malice
and
and anti-slab legislation but the idea
is you could sue the new york times
james o'keefe sued the new york times
because i think two reporters
made statements about him the new york
times as an organization is responsible
for publishing the speech of these
individuals
why they're just users on a website why
is the new york times responsible for
liab able to be sued over what users
wrote
because they're in their pay because
they're employees yeah
that means i should be able to
publish articles on timcast.com as
statements of fact and say whatever i
want about
about anybody and i can't be sued for it
if wikipedia can do it why can't i
yeah wikipedia has a has it has its uh
it's it's mastered wikipedia the free
encyclopedia
and then it has all of these statements
that are written by who i have no idea
yeah i don't think it should just be
because they're paid employees of new
york times and that's why new york times
is liable i think because like a social
network that has unpaid users if the
social network masks that and just post
the users comments as
like minds if mine's was to do that and
this is mine's
statement so we can oh that would also
be equally suitable
i would think so so this should mean
that i can open up
members of timcast.com to submit
articles
that i choose which will appear and just
say i didn't write it it was a user on
my website who submitted it
i just chose to have it published under
my brand name like wikipedia does
and you can click the source and see
only in the back end
a list of different people who
contributed to it and i p
oh only an ip address we have no idea
who wrote just ip
sue me what are they gonna do you know
maybe that's what i should do maybe i
should clone the wikipedia model
because what will happen is if someone
sues and wins i'll go oh
no then i'll turn around and see
wikipedia that's like for everything
if you're if they're committing war
atrocities against your people and you
start committing war atrocities against
theirs it's not necessarily the best
tactic i see your point i'm not saying i
prove a point like look how horrible
this is
no i'm saying we can write we can write
our opinions about people
i can look if wikipedia is issuing
opinion pieces
and starting their fact then why can't i
i think you legally can right now i
would you know what i'll do
i'll have users write articles and i'll
call it
the encyclopedia from timcast.com and
then i'll define encyclopedia and then
people can write whatever they want
at least make a movie about it like a
short five-minute ridiculous dystopian
nightmare wherever and then i'll just
i'll just say section 230 you can't sue
me
over what my users said and they'll say
yeah but you're the one who's choosing
what's get published
like so is wikipedia twitter twitter
bans people
they choose what's acceptable on their
site i am simply moderating
for for hate speech thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you